good morning millennial howdy doody I
want to work on my good driving
Millennials I want to work on my intro
okay I'm not in love with like my thing
you know
okay I like when you sing us in but you
know I do have a jewel lung and I can't
really sing unfortunately shoes
unfortunately for the viewers at home
I'm still suffering from a little bit of
popcorn lung as a residual of my badge
decision making over the weekend with my
jewel but it's not your lung that
Severine you maybe have popcorn throat I
just feel like it's all connected you
know yeah maybe you're just eating too
much popcorn I like mine this is my
shirt wait we have to just start about
your shirt we do so I don't know if the
viewers meed
it was my secret santa present from
Zach's brother oh that's cute isn't it
cute and he got me a greatest showmen
coffee table book that has all these
behind-the-scenes secrets about greatest
showmen and it was just so nice and he
also got me a greatest showman poster
that has like a really depressing quote
on it that you would think would be
inspirational it says all the shine of a
thousand spotlights will never be enough
for me Oh che like that song is so good
but what people realize is that it has
like a horrible message like anyone who
dances to that at their wedding like
it's a song about divorce adultery and
never being happy enough with what you
have a man's station is only limited by
his imagination can't relate to what
this one no exactly can't really so why
I declined the poster but back to your
shirt my shirt is a tweet a quote tweet
from someone who asked me sin Ramsey
how's your girl and how's your family
and he replied if they were any better
and be illegal so funny yeah a great
tweet like you know he didn't write it
no genius marketing guru he has genius
social media guru he does on his payroll
I'm feeling very um throaty today like
I'm very like The Grudge like sticky
shoes
can you do that well that's Pisan can
you do that it's not a strong you ever
seen the movie The Grudge no when me and
Marguerite younger we saw it was like
the only scary movie we ever saw and the
thing like the monster in The Grudge is
like that's like his thing and I used to
do it like when Margo was asleep and
scare her oh that's nice I was such a
nice sister real nice speaking of
spending time with my sisters I did make
it to SoulCycle yesterday and I am
paying the price heavily today you are a
sore
I'm only sore in your booty not in my
booty like I was trying to explain to
been where I'm sore cuz like it's not my
vagina but it's not my butt it's like if
I were a man it would be my Gooch yes no
that's where it hits you it's my baby
see when you tap it back that's where
you keep getting stabbed but I don't
have it back because of the sensitivity
it's like that's not my problem with
SoulCycle is like I could really keep up
if I was sitting the whole time but the
sitting is what hurts it's almost like
they do it on purpose to stand and like
get more core engaged but it hurts so
bad i litterly some of the heating past
like heating pad like on my ass also I
think that area is actually called the
scene is it yeah that cuz you know Gooch
you know that Steen actually means like
like the Gooch when you look it up an
urban dictionary okay but what is the
female Gooch called
I mean there is a vagina near about me
yeah but live where is that where cracks
a line who decides to cracks in a
redwood in a path that's so funny
where's being so like gross today yeah
no I'm but we also learned that steam in
Hebrew means to drink or be drunk so
appropriate like I've never heard
something that made more sense in my
life yeah Jackie I'm give me a lipstick
today and I'm just feeling like Jackie O
I mean this isn't really my signature
color but I'm thoroughly enjoying I did
say yesterday that I was being heavily
influenced by my sister Jackie it was
the day before yesterday yesterday well
what do I do say so overall what were
your thoughts I overall what were your
thoughts I'm not gonna put word thing
around my thoughts were this it's I
really have the same thoughts as I did
before it's like SoulCycle is too
heavily dependant
me having a good time in getting the
best possible workout is too heavily
reliant on the music tastes of someone
else and this was musical Mondays and it
was good but there was a lot of songs I
didn't know and like I wasn't feeling
inspired during the songs that I didn't
know and that sucks yeah I would say
usually I mean you can't have the exact
same taste as everyone but like Nicholas
is pretty seen most of the time yeah but
um he's also like way more of a theater
person than me or so he gets like me get
some songs that I've never heard but
usually like all the songs are so see me
like greatest showmen dear Ivan Hansen
hairspray etc even Mamma Mia cuz I like
the music and then one or two aren't but
I need those songs to breathe but there
were a few that we weren't really doing
request songs in advance and he played
both of them and I just have to say like
I might requests were so well-received
by the group and really brought me to
life like we started with the wizard and
I and I was like singing the ariana
grande version in my head I'm like that
really like I was like wow I'm gonna
work out every day and then by the end I
thought I'd thought I was gonna die and
throw up and I couldn't get off the bike
that's the thing it's like all the prep
and everyone there is like so cool like
we've been here before we know how to
get our class is actually really toasty
yeah oh it's a twister in the wild I
think oh like 75% of the class like
watches right now I hope I did a job I
was like feeling embarrassed dude I mean
bit mad at the chair like I didn't want
to be near people and I wanted to see
the mirror obviously but it's just it's
it's it's a mental game that's all cycle
you know it is you gotta get in the game
and you gotta get your head in the game
girls who sit in the front row and wear
sports bras a la Marga wash right yeah
people and I don't wear sports bra very
different yeah those girls are evil yeah
that's Mitch that's Emily Ratajkowski
yeah I was a machine mer yeah and I had
just watched I feel pretty in the whole
time I was thinking like my seats gonna
fall I'm gonna hit my head in my hair
it's gonna get caught you think you're
gonna have a new outlook on life and
you're gonna be the head of Lili LeClair
but I am Amy Schumer after her Hut got
hit maybe I would revert if I got my
head hit starving insecure I would be
the old Amy sure be like so insecure I'm
like never leave my house like only go
out with my two friends well actually
that is what I do anyway so and do your
hair for makeup too from YouTube
tutorials the movie is so good it's so
good
I watched it just recently and like I
think it's generally regarded as a bad
movie which I find check
I don't agree I don't agree and I don't
know that it is it's like only the
critics say that it's bad but who are
you creating the critics also said the
lobster was a good movie and that's just
I know that art is interpretive but that
is just an incorrect fact a theater
critic who can't find joy in the theater
okay PT Barnum um anything else you want
to catch up on it's in my whole day
yesterday revolves on the soul cycle I'd
such a pit before the whole day leading
up to it I'm like I'm gonna feel so good
afterwards and you know what I mean feel
good afterwards I thought I was gonna
throw up I'm sorry
he went home for my favorite meal and I
wasn't even excited about it I had to
take it home and then I was excited
about it
well how Athiya was he proud of you you
know I think he was upset that I left
him for so long and like didn't take him
with me but like I might imagine Theo
vernier on that soul cycle class oh it
had such bad anxiety about it's like
tail getting stuck in one of the wheels
and it would but you couldn't put him on
a bike he's so cute and precious he's a
job like he was being such a precious
and precious MJ me on the man yesterday
and we recorded our patreon episode
which is you know just taking the world
by storm II Webster all about our weight
loss um everyone's been so positive but
of course he really focus I'm the two
negative oh my god no I my response has
been like literally overwhelmingly
negative and I was in a mood last night
well if people say it was pissing me off
and then some girl were in The Bachelor
for me I was like done with my GM's last
night and I just had to turn it off and
like something look I really am above it
most of the time but look last night it
was just a night where it got to me
because like so many people were damning
me comments cuz I did an Instagram story
I'm like me and James and like people
have been so mean to me that I haven't
spoken enough about my weight loss but
you really like [ __ ] I talk about it
every day but I didn't speak enough
about it so great me did a whole episode
dedicated to it now I gave the haters
what they wanted and they're like how
can you even say that you had like a
weight loss journey like you got lap
band right that's what that's what I saw
didn't you get chin surgery yeah you
talk about the chin surgery or delayed
chin so talk about the chin surgery
every day on the show so we mentioned in
the episode but not oh that wasn't the
point yes I did get chin surgery and I
lost 40 pounds completely unrelated
issues I just like I couldn't with the
world lesson right and it's like so
flattering that people assume that you
got banned it's crazy
um but that's just not the case when
would we have had time right I guess
maybe not a major surgery fall break
I mean I'm our winter break oh no but
you lost
wait what if I took out the surgery
taking like time off or maybe you got it
when you got your chin down cuz we had a
few days off yeah I think that's when I
got it thank you
one how can Jackie clean kedo season and
two Claudia got lap-band but you did do
but we so what are you insinuating that
I did instead of quito season you don't
think I got surgery as well I mean I
would know I would be insulted if they
thought I got like that I was happy
totally it was just like honestly life
and then people were saying like that
before picture that we posted when we
did the before and after they were like
they were never this thick that's just a
bad picture I was like no I have you
should see the pictures we didn't post
that was a picture that I posted to my
Instagram after that event yeah decent
pic moving on so everyone take a xanax
and calm down no I mean if you have an
extra xanax please give one to me I was
just like so over humanity yesterday and
I was really thinking about like going
on like a crazy rant but when I see
other influencers doing that I'm like
[ __ ] just be grateful people care about
you so I guess I'm grateful in a sense
that people spend their time reading
writing comments about me but it was
just really annoying then some
homewrecker ruin the bachelor for me
after I was like I finally got into it
last night like I was like in the
episode I was like you know I could do
this every week and now I'm not gonna do
it anymore because I know who wins and
I'm just not interested and I won't
spoil it cuz I'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
to go out of your way to just DME like
you are an evil person like on the
inside you're a bad person agreed we'll
recap The Bachelor a note in a little
bit but I think before that are you
ready for the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast sure
sure I'm gonna say some pretty decent
stories first story the Recording
Academy says leaked list of winners is
fake I saw music lovers and stains
everywhere because it was put in our
group chat we're stunned to learn a
music chart dated Twitter account
published a so called list of Grammy
winners from the yet to be held ceremony
on Monday main pop data which describes
itself as a source for music news
released a lengthy list of winners for
the upcoming Grammy Grammy ceremony it
claimed cardi B will win record of the
year for I like it
as she should it also named H ER and
Lady Gaga has been big winners along
with Khloe exhale a and the Carters
however according to E News the
Recording Academy shut down any chatter
cleaning the release
mistake quote there is no legitimate see
no legitimacy to this Grammy Awards
results are not shared even with the
Recording Academy staff members until
the day of the Grammy Awards ceremony
when names of the recipients are
delivered by Deloitte in sealed
envelopes the organization told the site
the ceremony will be held on February
10th well here's the thing I think the
thing is is that I did see the video
someone just claimed that the website
accidentally put up the winners like I
said it was fact and they took a video
of it and I kind of don't think that
it's real for a million reasons one one
is that I really don't think anyone gets
the the results like until that day and
we're still like a couple weeks out or
two weeks whatever yeah like I think
it's really soon for them to already
have decided and put it like in text
form I really do think that like the day
before is when like they actually get to
like the website court night coordinator
like doesn't have access to right so
people think it was a hack like someone
hacked it and just came up with like the
most likely result oh that would be
weird the Grammys themselves likes
burning interest in their own show right
well now I
we got a tune in except I can't cuz I'll
be on stage at the Huntington Paramount
Theater I think it's cool and make sure
you're there February 10th
tickets available at girl with no job
calm and also what's a chi are for album
of the year whoo things that I've no
idea I'm gonna look it up cuz they said
they won Album of the year not keys my
screen so [ __ ]
well they said Taylor strip one pop
album of the year which is very possible
um
I mean very possible she was up against
like pink and ariana grande right okay h
er oh the singer's name is har har is a
compilation album by American singer HDR
oh that's helpful yeah that's like what
does the word protruding mean when
something protrudes that's the least
helpful thing you listen in her debut
album yeah yeah like a Taylor Swift um I
guess I'll have to become familiar with
it if it's the album of the year well I
don't think it's true I don't think
these are real I think it's just like it
was a hack and like someone's playing a
joke I'm a liar yes I'm not buying it
hilarious and honestly like the song I
like it it's really good
is record of the year really yeah the
middle was record of the year uh the
middle wins for pop vocals of the year
in the league tack I think I would I
think it's between I like it and the
middle and you can make the case for
either but I like it it's just so good I
feel like I like it
genre only Gossage and Hodge allure like
a couple months ago it was the song of
the summer in addition to the middle the
middle was the song of the winter the
middle was the song of the year so
record of the year so as I like it
yeah no it's good it's good and whatever
we're never here I like it all I think
the song is I don't like it I love love
love it Oh Flo Rida so underrated
where's khlo Ryder's Grammy
hello Rida is playing at Tortuga
Festival and we're gonna we're gonna go
I mean he had to it's in Florida and I
think of its like in his contract Oh
totally I forgot yeah he's obligated to
show up at every single festival that
takes place in the great state of
Florida every single Floridian festival
every single flow Rhydian that's all
okay next story drama and update in the
fire festival scandal kendall Jenner and
models may have to testify over failed
fire festival models and social media
stars who promoted the scandal late and
friar festival may be forced to testify
about the luxury weekend turned scam
according to a new court filing at least
five celebrities who created hyper on
the event including models kendall
Jenner Bella had to eat an Emily
Ratajkowski who are the other two like I
want to know I saw pictures with some
night girls Elsa hosk
I think I don't know they all look the
same there were so many of them and I
just wanna know who would the top five
who they consider who the courts
consider yeah that's true I guess
literally probably is by numbers like
who got paid the most or who is most
followers perhaps maybe requires an
answer questions about payments they
received from disgraced owner organizer
Billy McFarland according to court
papers filed in Manhattan federal
bankruptcy court Friday the subpoenas
are linked to an investigation into what
happened to the estimated twenty six
million dollars McFarlane spent in the
months before the fire festival imploded
with massive food shelter and security
problems many of the models were paid to
frolic in the Caribbean ocean for a
video promoting the event in spring 2017
in the court papers trustee Gregory
Messer demands to know what happened to
the roughly 5.2 million dollars worth of
festival cash so he owes about twenty
six million
like where is it that's what they're
trying to figure out and it's like I
don't think he put all of that into the
festival but it's like he didn't keep it
right and some stuff showed up with the
stage was but they never got paid but
yeah the models got paid yeah like no
these poor bohemian workers did it but
kendall Jenner do right and she's just
like mums the word on her so what are
they exactly subpoenaing like what are
they trying to get it's like information
maybe um confirming that they got paid
confirming payment yeah this is just so
shady and it's mostly shady for their
agency I think they're all with IMG
Models who they're the ones were
responsible for vetting all of these
opportunities and bringing them to the
models like they're the ones who should
be subpoenaed right it's like a level of
protection yeah it's not even like
they're they're not on trial for being
bad agents which is like that's Kendall
judges there should be on their on trial
for like they're the ones who
facilitated all the wire payments and
this and that in the contracts got it
yeah I guess that's true like he did
steal all this money like where did it
go right like kendall Jenner and like
doesn't know you know the the Payton
money trail right like she doesn't she
has a financial adviser she doesn't even
keep track of her finance it's like
someone else does that for her right and
anytime she wants money she just calls
Chris and Chris calls the financial
manager then when Rob asks for like all
that cash on a plane yeah that was so
shady
also what's weird is like if these
documentaries were never made like would
this Court ruling be proceeding right
now that's what he said last week it's
weird when like art influences life like
there are Kelly documentary but he had
been arrested if that documentary hadn't
taken like the world by storm that week
I don't know it doesn't sound like it I
mean no load but it was like so what we
can't have any justice and unless like
you have a whole documentary about you
alright so it looks like we have to make
a documentary about so many things but
well where do we begin
Lilly Moscovitz oh my Sharpay Evans we
should make it a documentary honestly
about Dayton Foster we don't deal with
wildly and oh my god let's do a
Kickstarter is that what it's called
yeah well look at me Kickstarter and not
GoFundMe GoFundMe is for charity
Kickstarter Zach when you raise money
for a business both no no I'll do the
same thing no GoFundMe in English our
hipster businesses yeah yeah that's
right now like IndieGoGo okay so he's
not strictly charting because picks up
people I guess
I guess they asked for its cause driven
yeah it's like Oh help me with my we
would do an IndieGoGo where it's like we
would crap crowdfund whatever and I'm
really gonna how that works for a
documentary yeah we would need a
documentary filmmaker I'm sure the
toaster there's a toaster he was like
has a real vision there's always a
toaster and we would do like our Kelly
six-part series it would be famous
couples throughout history who deserve
justice so episode one when I was to be
David Foster Yolanda Hadid episode 2 a
big balan cast on episode 3 would be
little maschwitz and her brother Sharpay
and Ryan episode we have to do payments
couple start history okay I could just
be tasting the teaser and that's what we
use to sell to the network's like yeah
here's the here's the we would be
straight-to-dvd
like we would just be direct to consumer
yeah but like you wanted the detail like
need someone to we need a production
company you know something that's why we
would have to crowdfund online yeah I
would we call it we would call it the
Justice files sorry the McKenzie file
the Justice League again hey wonder if
that's taken no I don't think so
doesn't ring a bell well I honestly I
don't feel like the models here are in
any way responsible like I do think it's
shitty that none of them have spoken up
or even donated to the cause but at the
end of the day like they were just doing
their job and it sucks that nobody like
had the foresight to be like maybe this
is a scam but it's not their fault
they're not responsible for from vetting
that the legitimacy of like music
festivals right that has a budget of at
least a million dollars if you have a
budget of a million dollars I think it's
the underlying assumption is like oh
you're legit yeah if you're paying me
like but it turns out they're only
banging right next to re exciting news
bachelor in paradise alums Jade and
Tanner expecting baby number two oh I
saw Jade repair Joubert and Tanner toe
bears family is expanding by the way for
some of the new toasters we we pose an
interesting philosophical question Jade
Roper got married to Tanner Tolbert now
her married name is Jade Rober Tolbert
now do you think it's pronounced Jade
Roper Tolbert or Jane Roe Toby let us
know in the comments of the YouTube
channel feed whatever it's called
I'm Monday the bachelor in paradise
alums and on some Instagram that they're
expecting their second child
together quote baby number two is adding
to our crew we are overjoyed our bundle
of love will be joining us in August
we've been dreaming of you for a while
now and you already loved beyond
imaginable sweet baby yeah I noticed
that typo when I read her caption it's
fine she's so cute she's still cute they
make cute babies and I feel like they
have a happy full life even though did
you watch their I'm home tour no okay
but they bought a mansion in where every
Kansas and it was like they took forever
to make it it was totally customized
every piece of furniture was customized
but it's like the cost of living in
Kansas is so much less than like if that
house was in New York it would be a 10
million dollar house and just the cost
of real estate so I think like I ends up
being like a 2 million dollar house and
he was so nice no and nay we're living
the dream they lap of luxury they have a
lake on the property he wants to do in
their life it's like let's go get some
cheap land bill mansion we'll be kings
yes they were truly the kings of camp
this second they finally finished that
house they decided to move to LA right
so now the house is either for sale or
already sold I want about it now they'll
get a condo in Marina del Rey for the
price of their house yeah they're living
next to scheana know their house was
just like so glam so HGTV like you know
that they just take good care of their
home and like all the cleaning products
like are organic and cheese
yeah I'm they're like local celebrities
they'll never have to you know it's
their neighbor living the dream totally
and maybe the message is like the dreams
not what it's talked out to be like
being the king of Kansas like I'd rather
be a nobody in LA really no but they yes
but they were living proof like they
were the kings of Kansas and now they're
choosing to not be so maybe it's not
everything what would you take the king
of Kansas my king of Kansas in a
heartbeat big fish small pond every time
yeah what about big fish big pond
oh my god I mean that's just an
unrealistic goal to set yeah but that
it's like saying I want to be a big fish
in New York okay what about medium fish
big pond it's not small not big medium
it's like no one else is gonna eat you
it's just like an average life no one
else gonna eat you but you're not eating
no I still wanna be the king of Kansas
I've been watching hard okay they're
medium fish big pond now because they
are you know celebrities we are talking
about them in the past time yeah I just
wonder what they're gonna move into like
a house an apartment I really I need a
tour yeah and I'm sure she'll give you
one yeah it would just take two years by
the way have you ever used brand lists
no but I've heard such a good thing I
just started using it cuz they just
started working with the toast and
honestly it has changed my life as an
online shopper you know me like I
literally I have an app for everything I
can't stop purchasing items especially
for my home because I'm a homemaker now
that I've been home off tour for about a
month I have decided to become mrs.
fields
who's the homemaker uh Martha Stewart
Betty Crocker Betty Crocker yeah except
I don't really babe mrs. fields makes
cookies but so bradley's I started to
use when it comes to choosing a product
that's better than the rest just one
label matters and its brand less brand
less believes in making better products
are more affordable and accessible
prices to everyone why sift through
hundreds of brands at big-box stores
only to pay a premium for disappointing
quality so bran list has more options
that you care about they cut out the
middleman and they just deliver to you
just what matters so our listeners can
get $10 off your first order of $50 or
more and free shipping up brand let's go
to Brandis comm code toast to start
saving on high-quality products don't
wait a second longer toasters go on
brand list.com
enter code toast to get $10 off your
first orders of $50 and free shipping
start and join high-quality products you
deserve oh I'm so down I just like every
time I get my quality products honestly
I'm someone who's like so duped by
brands yeah so every time I get home
there's like literally six boxes in my
hallway and it's actually embarrassing
yeah and like it's heavy I was gonna say
unloading boxes it's like so much work
I'd literally start sweating because now
I'm like on like a clean freak so I've
gotta like dust up all the debris what
was the other word shrapnel and then
also you don't have you got a deacon
truck the boxes and put in the garbage
room that's like my least favorite part
okay I'm not gonna lie like sometimes I
don't do it I don't I'm waiting to get
yelled out for my building about like
the recycling of it all okay recycle but
I just put the boxes up write them all
we use them again how do you even
recycle honestly they're just a
recycling bin I'm gonna put one in there
the boxes we recycled build materials
but some like no but you supposed to be
in bottles bottles yeah yeah cans so
just like anything like food stuff it
would be garbage yeah seems like
everything is recyclable no no all right
not food maybe I'll start separating
that's okay that's a good resolution
that is a good breathily I mean now it
makes sense
under my sink there's two garbage cans
I guess one is for okay so like glass
bottles is that receivable mm-hmm
aluminum cans water bottles plastic
bottles what else make paper bags from
the store
people please paper what if it's used I
think now no I think no - yeah and
actually no papers not recyclable yeah
cuz paper is the plastic alternative
papers worse like paper sheets of paper
like you put them in the recycling bin
you do yeah I would always put them in
the library after I finished a big day
and they got it back my gosh okay that's
I'm gonna work on it okay
now for two stories that are really more
you know crime business tech man crime
business crime a business in crime I was
reading the paper yesterday which one
the New York Post
okay and I came across as well as the
cover stories I didn't really campus
graze he walked by a newsstand
essentially great but I read the story
and it's crazy and I go like the
toasters are in I don't think I know oh
no you don't doctor said brain dead
doctor said brain dead man was my
brother he wasn't what they were
switched at death a horrific hospital
mix-up left a Brooklyn woman grieving
for nine days at the bedside of a
brain-damaged man who doctors insisted
was her brother but who was actually a
stranger with the same name a new
lawsuit charges but did she see his face
but I'm gonna read the whole strikes I
had all these questions but only after
she gave consent to have her brother
taken off of life support at st.
Barnabas Hospital did sure al Powell
earnest shocking truth
her real sibling was in jail and she had
just sent a stranger to his death
her Bronx Supreme Court lawsuit says
quote I nearly fainted because I killed
somebody that I didn't even know I gave
consent said Powell forty-eight of Crown
Heights I was like where's my brother
what is going on I was devastated
the saga began July 15th when Freddie
Clarence Williams forty was admitted to
the Bronx hospital unconscious from an
apparent drug overdose
according to Powell's lawsuit Williams
had his social security card on him and
it identified him by that name the court
papers say but the hospital phoned
Powell
anyway telling her that her brother
Frederick Williams who was also 40 but
has no middle name had been in minute
and was near death she rushed to his
bedside whoa [ __ ] he had tubes in his
mouth a neck brace she told the post he
was a little swollen but he were
my brother so much he couldn't speak
from the time they brought him in the
hospital they just assumed it was my
brother after two days of testing
Barnabas doctors told her that her
brother was brain dead she said quote
that's my baby brother so it was really
hurtful
I was worried hurt crying screaming
calling everybody it was a horrible
feeling with no cause to hope for his
recovery she contacted relatives down
south telling them to come and say their
goodbyes
Powell acknowledged that the first time
her sister saw the ailing man in the
hospital she questioned whether he was
her sibling she walked into the room and
said that is not my brother I said what
do you mean the guy was much bigger she
explained but he appeared swollen and
quote the eyebrows the nose the
structure looks like our brother my
sister she walked up closer and you
could see the resemblance and she was
like oh okay so he was clearly all
messed up rimmel her features and it's
like if it's a brunette white man like
how different can they look yes but
they're I think they're both black men
Oh so on July 29th with her uncle and
sister at her side
Powell authorized the hospital and
withdraw life support from fried
chickens the lawsuit says it was very
devastating she recalled I was crying
fried chick Williams death was either
harder on was even harder on his two
daughters Brooklyn and daughters the
daughters of who they thought died yeah
okay so another real daughters the teens
live in Virginia in Brooklyn and came to
the city to say goodbye to their father
before he was taken off of life support
she was hysterical she was holding his
hand kissing him crying only after an
autopsy did the medical examiner's
office reveal the truth the dead man was
Freddie Clarence Williams Powell said
they got a call from a worker on an
agency as they were making funeral
arrangements she called us just in time
we would have been burying someone else
meanwhile it turned up how his actual
brother was in jail on a July first
assault arrest in lower Manhattan but
she doesn't know her brothers in jail
Powell went to Manhattan Supreme Court
her siblings next hearing a few weeks
later just to lay eyes on him I saw my
brother I couldn't believe it I was very
relieved she also called him on the
phone at Rikers Island they had quite a
conversation about her decision to pull
the plug
he was saying you were going to kill me
I explained to him once you Braden it
there's nothing you can do right
interviewed at Rikers Power Powell's
brother said he had forgiven his sister
for pulling the plug on the man she
thought was him the doctors told her
they couldn't do anything I'm
mad at her still he raged how could the
hospital do something like that look
what they put my family through anyways
obviously they're filing a lawsuit
wait now side by side pictures of the
men they do not this is um I think this
is a man who's in jail but no the
deceased man still no information about
him I mean I see this story from two
lenses one this is the greatest story
and also it's the worst story I ever
heard like this woman she spent ten days
thinking that her brother died like when
someone just recently dies the only
thing in the world that you want to
happen is for this person to come back
which is literally impossible but it
happened like wow how amazing but then
also this poor man where's his family
they don't get to make the decision who
is he who is he yeah that's still like
not answered that's really sad
but yeah it's nice that they have a
second chance with their brother right
and then like this brother is in jail
and all he hears is your sister killed
oh right and now you know like that's
that they would do Chucky that's a
[ __ ] crazy story crazy so right and I
thought what was the New York Post
headline I'm sure it was tough funny
doctor said I don't know what the cover
story was but it just says doctor said
brain-dead man was my brother he wasn't
sued that's crazy oh my god they're
gonna sue the [ __ ] what's the hospital
um st. Barnabas but then the hospital
saying they have no claim we don't feel
there's any merit to this claim because
they're seeking unspecified damages I
mean you know it's just like honestly
this woman doesn't have the right to sue
the family of the man who died does
right but where are they I don't even
know if they found him right and what
happened to the man that landed him in
the hospital uh drug overdose oh and he
really was truly brain-dead so it seemed
like the humane decision I mean
depending would be believed right but it
wasn't like she was she was trying to
kill her brother I mean let's say this
was the situation with us god forbid a
many times I got one and you were brain
dead and after ten days I decided to
pull the plug then you found out that I
pulled the plug on you when you had like
no chance of living like would you be
angry at me no I don't think so either
I have you just be sorry I put you in
that position oh okay no I would just be
like no why should you have to like pay
my bills when I'm not waking up yeah
there's so much easier said than done
like you know right and we you know I
feel like I decide which is brain-dead
yeah maybe right now there's no hope for
them but you never know what's gonna
happen with modern medicine it leads me
to our fifth story oh wow I love a good
segue we will have a cure for cancer
within a year oh my god I'm so glad you
do this you guys we will have a cure for
cancer within a year scientists claim a
team of Israeli scientists they claim
they will likely develop a cure for
cancer in the next year the Jerusalem
forcer Post reported on Monday I love
the Jerusalem Post do you think that's
really course Jerusalem pours and that's
where they got their ears parsed totally
the new treatment is being developed by
accelerated evolution bio technologies
under the leadership of CEO dr. Ilan
Murad according to the report quote we
will we believe we will offer in a
year's time a complete cure for cancer
said Dan I adore chairman of the
company's board quote art cancer cure
will be effective from day one will last
a duration of a few weeks and will have
no or minimal side effects at a much
lower cost than most other treatments on
the market the treatment called mute at
how the couldn't have govern association
question Nemo yeah TBD
muchacho it's fellow mu T ATO will tell
Joe new Tata all right let's think is
this really what that's all yeah we'll
use a combination of cancer targeting
peptides and a toxin that will
specifically kill cancer cells the trim
will eventually be personalized in this
specific cocktail of the drugs will be
given to patients based on their type of
cancer Mourad told the newspaper so this
isn't just one type of cancer being
cured it's like all of it it's like we
found the cure for cancer no I know why
isn't art by more people talking about
that I guess because it hasn't been like
it's not like release right it's not
it's preliminary yeah we don't want to
necessarily live in our chickens before
they hatch but the Israelis are very
superstitious puns I don't think they
would be saying this if it wasn't legit
as hell so they said they found the cure
and in about a year you'll be able to
start using it yeah wait that's so like
amazing I mean like cancer what are we
gonna say it's not like you cured cancer
no it's like that we got a cure leprosy
or some [ __ ] right Lou Gehrig's we need
to care a brain deadness that's next
but that is just so grazi and I didn't
see this written up anywhere no except
for the New York Post and I was looking
for stories and thank God I went to an
actual person not page six or else I
wouldn't have even seen it right so we
did it goes
use code toast we're here curious yeah
it's actually toasted Ted no any air
when this comes out we will try and get
you a promo code right so now you know
there's a conspiracy theory that cancer
has been curable forever there's a
conspiracy theory by Vince offer
oh Willy it's his theory no Jackie it's
like a berry it's like Bush did 9/11
it's like one of those it's his theory
that like he heard somewhere and he's
the one to see emanating you would have
never heard of it if it weren't for your
husband no that's I haven't heard it
from anyone at Jackie when i retweeted
this Jerusalem Post article last night
all the comments were like we've had it
like it's a very it take a very
well-known but like not legitimate
conspiracy theory that we've had the
cure to cancer forever but like cancer
drugs and cancer treatments generates so
much money for like insurance companies
and the big pharma companies that
they've just decided not to release it
right or like you know that people
eventually like have to die so they're
just letting people die yeah like
natural selection is no it's like it's
just like okay if they find the cure to
every disease and everything that would
be so wonderful but then like though the
planet will be overpopulated now oh that
is like such a selfish there no I mean
I'm saying that's part of the conspiracy
yeah I just don't think that the world
is that evil like there are people who
would like let other people die even
though they have like the key to life
right and then I'm sure it's like like
Prince Philip and like rich people okay
yeah oh my god of course not anymore not
anymore I think I mean it's really even
if they had the cure for awhile it's
time that cancer scare because it's
obviously extremely prevalent feels like
now more so than ever yeah and it's like
what holy it was like right we've got to
move on from this disease right like the
humans are evolving and we've just got
to figure it out like it's disappointing
that before this week you hadn't figured
it out yeah it's a we put a man on the
moon that would be just so crazy if we
can say like in our generation
cancer is cured and like if you got a
cancer diagnosis it's not gonna what
like it's not it's not a death sentence
I'm telling you oh it's still not like
it necessarily a death sentence like
there are a lot of treatments but
they're so taxing you have to be like
just the right stage of cancerous and
etc yeah lose your hair I just can't
believe like minimal side effects I
heard great sir yes you did
essentially that was just fees so I look
forward to meeting here from in a year
from now me too
I'd like I want to follow up in a year
I'm gonna set an alarm on my phone for
next year
yeah we're lining up a Google Alert I
mean you'll probably get a lot of [ __ ]
but like cancer is cured you like wake
me up on January 29th 2020
yeah we're saving lives we are we were
in a blender and now we're saving lives
isn't it amazing
that's so crazy it's also just so
disappointing that nobody's talking
about it
I know well that's what we're here for
yeah to spark conversation because you
know the media they only want you to
talk about certain things that nobody
even cares about and then they don't
even really harp on Bryan Singer being a
predator right I wonder how accessible
it's gonna be like is it just a drug
that anyone can get like a prescription
for it sounded pretty explore that guy
and it has a drug war cost it said what
it said yeah I'll read the quote again
because remember that guy who would like
the cure for AIDS or something and he
made it like a billion dollars and then
he ends up going to jail for something I
Martin shkreli yeah our Cancer Care will
be effective from day one the last
iteration of a few weeks and we'll have
no or minimal side effects at a much
lower cost
well then most other treatments on the
market a moot at o2 ok so much TV was on
last night I literally was in bed for
like 7:30 to 11 positive news I know
it's open it's just like today was a
very positive show because we had you
know switch at death which oh yeah has a
positive a happy and a double-edged
sword happy ending for some people um
muchacho that's gonna be like an episode
of Law & Order there were a pair toe
bout toe bears
Roberto Burt what else did we talk about
just positive happy bright shiny lights
that's us I really feel like the glasses
full good guys this fall today you know
I feel like [ __ ] per usual nah my the
glasses full actually for me I've had it
a new experience a new a new feeling
that I have never felt in my life going
on a trip this weekend I'm not gonna be
here Thursday Friday or Monday I'm sorry
guys my best friend the world on us
getting married
oh but programming update Thursday we
will have just
podcast episode for you Friday hashtag
snitch on the toast and Monday Darren
Karp is hosting with me to break down
everything about a nice baby shower yeah
so it's fine like you'll be fine yeah
but I'm so excited she's marrying her
highschool sweetheart like I know them
both really well it's like I'm a
bridesmaid like I'm like it's a first
wedding I've been to that I'm a part of
that I'm not related to you know so I'm
just really excited and it's in Mexico
and for the first time in my life like
I'm not running around the week of
getting close like I have addressed for
everything and there's a million so he
is Moroccan and like Yemenite I think so
there's a henna so you need like a
special sparkly dress for that then
there's a Shabbat I just came from a
sparkle party that's something and I
dress that at that from revolve that
never came is what I'm gonna wear then
and also there's a Friday night Shabbat
dinner then there's a Saturday day like
garden lunch vibe
then Saturday night I've made plans to
go to catch and Playa del Carmen because
I've been wanting to go to the new catch
and it's right around the hotel then
Sunday's the wedding like there's just
so many different outfits and like not
only do I have a dress for every
occasion I have options
Wow and I've never felt that way before
and I just I'm feeling like like Giselle
this might be what must be what Giselle
sounds like and me feels like but just
how also as someone to pack for her and
like that's what I need next because I
just can't take this on right now I feel
like she packs for herself though like
no no yes she's very hands-on and like
aggressive I feel like she sits on her
own suitcase and zips it I mean it
wouldn't even help if she sat on it and
her and their kids sit on it yes she's
like six of her kids sit on and they had
the old one yeah the one who kissed Tom
on the woods and the one who's not hurt
triage it Moynihan's yeah I had heard a
rumor that Bridget Moynahan skids lives
with him yeah I know so someone told me
that wasn't true I need to stop just
believing like things in my DMS as truth
because you know what I gotta do em
yesterday that Lady Gaga called off her
wedding no I don't know if it's true but
someone told it to me that's an
interesting factory that's well
interesting especially given you know
the Bradley Cooper of it all right but
they were a little at the SAG Awards
together not two days ago and I got this
diem yesterday did you even I'm a
wedding planned no but I guess like I
mean I think she's all off your
engagement should be engaged yeah that's
what celebrities do they just get
engaged for the jewelry yeah and like
the write-up
did you see Priyanka daniken look
another wedding party now they're to his
dad's something they're so out of
control but I'm I'm glad it's really
dying down and now they have to like
live with each other and decide like was
it all worth it this is the decision you
made like yeah
this is your major bed laying it maybe
they're comfortable I hope so because
that would be like really sad there's no
way they would break up at this point
there they will say together for at
least five years just just to say that
this is even a five-year marriage and
Hollywood is a success yeah and then it
will be like heartbreaking like oh my
god you can subscribe your marriage
lesson on The Bachelor
we got a wrench thrown at us nut wrench
what's the word wrench oh sure
the girlhood the first I can't I said
like literally we're down to half the
girls and I still don't know any other
guy first the girl who had the first one
on one
Teesha oh yes who went bungee jumping oh
my god I would've rather died she was
Devon I live in make away just for the
girls just for the girls justice for the
girls just for the girls screaming for
the girls shame shame shame e-platform
streaming platform streaming peppermint
streaming vibes Jamie vibes I mean I
know that [ __ ] date looked like my
worst nightmare and first of all I was
thinking like if that was me I hardcore
wouldn't go and like what whether that
gets me kicked off the show or not I
don't care if you're if you're gonna
dictate how much you love me based on
the mean I wanted to jump off a [ __ ]
bridge in a foreign country like you're
nuts
no I would not jump off and if I were
like if I was into the guy like I would
just probably make something up about
like a traumatic story of why you know
but on the bachelor they would make you
overcome it no no not about me like it's
someone that I know like bungee jump to
their death therefore I will never know
and then it's like oh they make you they
tell like someone once told me that they
make you break down like where you're
afraid up and then they put you on that
date right but she wasn't really afraid
of not she where it seemed like more of
a thing for Colton she actually seemed
like a good partner because she was like
scared she wasn't a psychopath he was
like excited to jump a thousand feet but
she was like more into it than he was
yeah well she jumped in the worst way
because your legs are tied up so you
want you hang upside down
she went legs first so she had to
ker-plop
you're supposed to go headfirst because
that's the way you bungee but her legs
were up so she went like this into it I
can't
my worst nightmare my worst nightmare
like when every time they jumped it's
like you're free falling for so long
before you
hoing I mean and like what is the what
are these diss companies credentials
like I would need to see some sort of
license I don't know like it looks
really legit and like Singapore like has
their [ __ ] together you know I don't
care I would never do it like I don't
like I value my life so I would never do
it Ben I test I don't test God you know
I would never ever ever ever do it ever
ever ever ever like the most craziest
thing I'll do it was like the Giant
Swing I camp toes yeah that's even
[ __ ] wild yeah but that's like a
literally like 40 feet yeah that was
1,000 feet is that what it was like
that's like a football field I mean
that's how they did it but she was cute
she looked really cute I liked her
outfit she had a good energy like do I
think it's the great love of our
lifetime no but she'll stick around for
a while she'll stick around she'll like
crush it in paradise he's such a cute
little boy like key personality yeah
very epi despite you know having having
been divorced and that's that was Chuck
chucking in like that can just like you
know really ruin someone's spirit yeah
but she was very spirited regardless and
I thought that that was a good testament
to her character yeah and then the group
date after that was which one they
walked around the shook oh my god that
was like the worst day dad was on his
back honestly I loved Emmy me too like
she lost like I was so on her side she
loves me a little bit with the c-word
you can't say the word cancer like it's
not nice you know oh oh my god now we
use the c-word even though no it's not a
cure for it great um no but that's like
a same this girl like blew it up so much
and I don't know whether or not this
girl was the cancer of the house but in
every season there is a cancer of the
house I don't know whether she was a
cancer of the house but in this
particular scenario she couldn't have
been more wrong and she had to go home
and she had to go home and I really
didn't think Debbie's plan was gonna
work I got both of them out I thought
that Demi like I thought Courtney was
gonna go home on her totally until Demi
said something it's like now she created
drama with Courtney and now Colton has
success both out I thought Demi actually
saved her by bringing her up even and
even Colton didn't even know who she was
before right and that whole that group
date night was actually the most
out-of-control thing I've ever seen in
my life and what's so funny is like I
feel like The Bachelor
producers are now getting a little bit
more like clogged because they paint a
villain and we all believe them and they
painted Demi as the villain kind of but
then in this scenario she could she
literally was so rational and she did
the right thing like Courtney is sitting
there moping around that she hasn't had
any time with Colton and Jimmy's
encouraging her she's like just do a
you'll feel so much better just get up
go go
thirty minutes she sat there telling her
all right so you're not gonna do it can
I go now right also know the bachelors
now like the producers instead of being
like villain saying it's like there's a
fight and it's very ambiguous right
who's right and who's wrong much like
the perils
and they're trying to like you know make
us think a little bit more and taste a
little bit more clear-cut than the
pageant because the pageant they still
haven't told us what exactly happened
right and and I guess they never will
right but they settle didn't very mature
way right and there they were being such
pageant girls about it like well yeah
first of all the minute that Caitlyn and
by the way I know that Kalyan in this
scenario
like I think healin is the villain
actually I think so too ever I am anti
Hanabi at this point just because of the
way she's gone about everything she's
been so annoying she was the first one
to bring it up to Colton and then was
upset when Kalyn defended herself and
talked [ __ ] about how many but it's like
you wouldn't have even been in her mouth
if you didn't mention it to Colton told
his self-inflicted self-inflicted then
she's getting upset that Kalyn got a
one-on-one when happy when she already
had a was disappointed that it wasn't
her when literally there was no chance
in hell it was gonna be you I'm like
ruined Joy's being delusional and three
Kalyn was a bigger person and went up to
Hannah B and the moment she like said
hey can we talk
it was squashed like yeah I felt like
the good bags and I've know that feeling
when you hate someone so much you just
don't care anymore
no and then like all they have to do is
just one small gesture and it just all
goes away all of a sudden yeah and
that's what I felt like it was for them
it's like they couldn't even remember
why they didn't like each other you know
but I was only because Kalyn was a
bigger person and said something so even
though I think that whatever happened I
think was Caitlyn's fault agreed that
was the vibe that I got but on this show
Kalyn is in the right and Hannah B is in
the wrong and especially after last
night after healing hearing Kalyn story
like and five and by the way after Kalyn
was the only woman who got Colton to
talk about Aly Raisman even in a
circumvent circumvented way he did it
okay let's just go chronologically so we
don't get all over the place group date
the Kourtney and the Demi of it all that
fight was so funny
Courtney's out of control like I was
being so weird and watching Debbie's
face move like she was trying not to be
so shocked by the things that she was
saying but she was so shocked and Jamie
says shocking things so yeah for her to
be shocked was shocking I mean I think
literally the most immature thing you
can do is I comment on someone else's
age like I said like either being like
you're so immature like you're just like
an old woman here at the seamy right
that's the best part
she said how old are you again she
really actually didn't know because if
she did she wouldn't said that and
that's just like the most derogatory
thing like literally it's so doesn't
matter how old you are
and I was just like hating Courtney so
much like she's obviously never seen an
episode of The Bachelor in her whole
life because she
that every girl every producer and
Colton are there to make sure she gets
enough time it's like [ __ ] this is a
Lord of the Flies everyone it's for
themselves no man every man left behind
like if you can't get it that's your
problem
right and so what everyone should sit
around while she works up the nerve oh
wait
she finally works up the nerve to talk
to Colton and it's all about Jimmy yeah
so stupid so stupid then in terms of the
other relationships that are brewing on
the group date
Hannah gee this was the first time I saw
crack in their relationship because they
didn't have anything to talk about and I
tell you someone they just started
making out and dry humping and it's like
okay now he's that now which I'm just
seeing lust like he's thinks you're so
beautiful which you are but maybe
there's not that much in common and now
I'm seeing like there was a time when he
would talk to her and or he would see
her and there was no one else in the
room I was like how was any other girl
gonna penetrate that because I really
don't think she wins so someone else
came through and now I'm seeing it's
like he goes on these dates with other
girls like he really has like good
conversations in bachelor world right
and then he sits down with Hannah gee
he's giving her as much privacy as he
possibly can and she has nothing to
really say other than I'm happy I'm here
and I'm nervous and and see how it's
obvious that she's watched one too many
episodes of The Bachelor because she
knows in order to get a rose like you
have to open up about something but it
seems like she's had a very easy life
she's like you know it's hard for me to
open up right she's like and then she's
like I'm so glad I opened up to you
about that it's like she knew she was
being so fake in that scene because she
had nothing to talk about it be she
wanted there to be a moment like Demi
opened up about her mom and the divorce
and also sexual assault like if you open
up like it starts a connection with
someone but she really didn't have
anything to open up about so she was
just saying like you know it's hard for
me right but also I think she's waiting
if she does have something to open time
about she's waiting for her one-on-one
otherwise what are we what are they
gonna talk about that she's not gonna
give it all the way no totally she
doesn't have one yet right and I think
hopefully she has one next week like she
[ __ ] deserves one yeah I want it and
he needs to see if there is something
between them more than just she's the
most beautiful girl I've ever seen like
they need to follow up from the first
impression rose
right I need a second impression I hope
it's next week the Chi gets her
one-on-one
well the girl who's never been kissed
has the one-on-one cuz I saw that in the
program an echidna kiss under the sky
with fireworks and I actually love her
seems she's fun she's such a cutie and
then there's Cassie who at first I was
like oh she's just like boy and play
clash or contestant but then what they
had a good camera
and last night during the group date and
then they played fairytale music so
she's a real contender and also she
cried
which is a very Lauren B move and a very
Shawn B moves yes so she got my
attention she cried because she's like
I'm in love with someone and he's taking
Kaitlyn shopping she she got my
attention for sure as someone who is to
be taken seriously and next week they go
to a private island together she has the
one-on-one was that her I thought it was
the girls nibbling kissed know the girls
everyone kiss has that Stephanie doesn't
have a that's so unfair that's so unfair
regardless they go to a private island
which is you know where Brad took Emily
mean are not a private island where they
fell in love and it was just beautiful
if you're going to a private island like
your frontrunner yeah if you got a
private jet you're also front row right
if you're bungee jumping you're fun
contestant yeah you're a bachelor in
paradise material right but if you get a
private jet you're about to write
material and if you're a first date I
don't think anyone who's ever gotten the
first date has has one maybe one person
it's not fair it's like but it's like
that's if I went on the air that's what
I would want I would want the first date
because then it unless you totally
[ __ ] botch it
it gets you pretty much - Final Four
assuming you're just like normal and and
consistently the first - Hannah be
consistent and then apparently next week
what is she doing I can't remember
she was really annoying me she was
really when I first I was kind of on her
side because she seemed like she really
was wrong whatever happened at the
pageant no she's really annoying me she
has gotta go she's not cut out for the
show and I just I just assumed that she
was decent but now she's just [ __ ]
annoying I understand she's like goofy
and her facial expressions are like
funny but it's not translating for
television um and then Kailyn state what
did they do they went shopping before
the last person who got that shopping
date was Becca kufran Arie took her
shopping for all that stuff so maybe a
Homa girl gets the final rose and then
it gets taken away from her - that all
the dresses I'm sorry we're so [ __ ]
heinous like I wasn't jealous at all
like some of them I wasn't jealous at
all I wasn't jealous at all cuz it was
very Giovanni up and I know and those
shoes she pulled out like I don't even
know if they were real Valentino they
were honestly so ugly and all the girls
were like honestly ugly yeah it's just I
thought it was like shiny low budget
that's my idea of the worst day yeah
shopping is exhausting that's why you
shop til you drop so like I wouldn't
want to do that like as a romantic
activity no me neither
and it's also like a lot of work on your
legs and just I don't care if someone
else is footing the bill that doesn't
make the day any less treacherous agree
and it was like a short date much okay
not to be here yeah just like don't
watch me when she went home I thought
the date was over I'm like it's very
rare that they go home yeah if they
wanted to show up to that they should
date just to piss off the other girls
like it was never a real one-on-one but
I'm not trying to be a [ __ ] like did
she not wear makeup during the day she
looked so different oh really she
definitely wasn't wearing lipstick I
think she had a day looking at night
look which I appreciate me too
so she got to go home and change
anything so fair I'm so unfair I think
there's a point in the show like you
have to wear a little less makeup cuz
you don't want to be look completely
different
yeah well I would have to like for me it
would be really hard I look so different
with him in that wake up like for one of
the some things I would just have to
like give a taste of like no but even
have to just like do eyebrows and
bronzer yeah eyebrows mascara whatever
anyways not that really Jamie is someone
who looks very different without makeup
yep and Elise with her light hair
probably also yeah anyways then the
dinner date I knew that she had seen
online I think they told people just
like a trigger warning um that she was
gonna talk about in experience with
sexual assault but I did not know she
was gonna like say the story and
honestly it was the worst story I've
ever heard he was literally an episode
of SVU it was the worst story I've ever
heard I saw the same thing he saw I
didn't read it or anything and I haven't
heard it maybe in the toasters group
that that was her cause during the
pageant sexual assault so she's really
like turned this horrible thing into
such a positive um the story was brutal
and she really like didn't she didn't
mince words like she was so like
stronger I'm talking about it and I
can't imagine like she couldn't have
done any like she couldn't have just
been any better stronger about it it was
really inspiring yeah and more poised
and like I just I really made me really
like her and see her differently and
soon sin take and like hurt and even
more and take hers hiding him and then
when someone like opens up to you about
that like there's really nothing you can
say cuz like it's just like it's
terrible and and what can you say and
obviously closed and handled it looks
just like a champ and talking about and
that's what brother
we said on this child like people think
it's so weird that he was a virgin
especially was in this like a
high-profile relationship with this
other and no it makes a lot of sense
like she was a victim of sexual abuse
he's like I had my reasons why I'm a
virgin because people who have been
sexually assaulted they don't just jump
into bed like everyone else like it's it
affects your intimacy and so I think he
addressed that in a way where he didn't
directly say Ally's name or like Larry
Nasser's name which like wouldn't have
been appropriate but he did open up
being like hey like people think I'm
weird for being a virgin but like I was
in a relationship for a long time and
she was already that's very fine and
very normal so I he's like a perfect
person to have received that information
you know I thought he handled it I was
so impressed by the way she handled it
same and I think that she was too and it
really I think these two have legs
together
me too I don't know she makes it all the
way cuz i just i don't see sparks you
know yeah but i do see this like common
ground that's a great like foundation
and she really can trust him as she said
like I trust Colton I don't mean maybe
to I would I trust him so much like I
feel so safe when he's on my team me too
and that is not how I felt in a very
long time Mike was on my TV I did not
feel safe I mean I felt like there was a
home invader like in my house every
Monday at 8 o'clock I was being robbed
by a thief in a bearded mask but when
Ben Higgins was on I felt safe oh yeah
for sure so anyways I thought that was
it was the first time in such a long
time where I literally my eyes were
glued to my TV I wasn't looking at
anything else I was paying attention I
don't think they they I don't think they
cut or edited any of what she said like
I think that whole conversation was as
it happened or at least I hope that it
was and I just I was so present for it
and I thought they handled it in a very
respectful way they had to add at the
end you know for this hotline they're
responsible I just think and they didn't
even talk about how that she liked her
cause in the pageant was sexual start
related so she how she turned something
so negative into something so positive
and she was like you know everyone
handles it differently I you know became
like a real justice seeker which I can
you know we seek justice over like that
I just had so much respect for her I
don't think she could have handled it
any better in her life and in this
situation and I just like kudos to her
also what was I gonna say
Colton is a bad kisser because everybody
kisses looks so disgusting when he was
kissing
he was gonna throw up oh really but he
was kissing having Jeannie I was like
this isn't cute and I thought it was on
her part no and so when when everyone
looks gross kissing him I'm like oh
maybe it's him maybe I just love him so
much I'm so like and I feel like he's
not one of these bachelors where it's
like there's one thing he keeps saying
over and over like Ari was like I love
that yeah yeah yeah and I I just feel
like every conversations different it's
as much as it could as much as it can be
different I think he's just doing such a
good job and like I just I love him so
much I haven't felt this way in so long
so we need Courtney and Traci go home
Traci has been very quiet since the
beginning and on the table misses and
Odie
yeah totally I won't miss her and I mean
it was time she went home before she
really got arrested please horrible even
Instagram BIOS wardrobe stylist like I
just wouldn't promote that about you if
you're gonna like you're a horrible
advertiser I'm the gear walking
representation of your brand's right and
it's like bad bad add I thought it was
weird that they did send Mattie home in
her bad week they I did think it was
weird that they sent corny huh usually
like if you start a fight with someone
you get at least another episode just
just to bleed into yeah and just to find
out who's you know right in his room but
so not only did Courtney get in a fight
on one episode she also got sent home
the same exact episode which like never
happens I thought I'm like there for
sure just gonna give it a try see cuz
she's been quiet and Demi was like I
mean I [ __ ] hate Tracy but she's
nervous to be here more the Courtney
does I what I really like Demi do and I
don't know if I feel you know who she
reminds me of a little bit just in her
spirit and the way that she talks Korean
yes but she also looks exactly like
Olivia Creedy oh I wasn't talking looks
just like in her I don't give a [ __ ]
vibe and a lot of her interviews I think
that she is drunk and she doesn't care
and she just says whatever comes to her
mind and I appreciate that because
everyone is like I love this I'm yeah
it's so serious you know all the girls
who are just like friends with each
other cute fine but there definitely are
people who are at a cancer in the house
and we're know that it was Courtney but
if it was like and some girls are there
just for fun and that's not being there
for the wrong reasons it's called being
on TV yeah but I don't think Demi is
there to be on TV like but also I don't
think she's there like you know
necessarily to be a wife and a mother
but I don't think her intentions aren't
that much different than anyone else no
me neither but I don't think she's
really there like for the love of her
life no okay let's work with Vanderpump
rules honestly when the bachelor is over
I was just like so excited
dive into mana from pearls it's really
my favorite show on TV and it never
disappoints so many things happened we
got to see the inside of TomTom and
honestly it looks so good
yeah I need some food there yeah I think
they have like bike it was giving me
just like cocktail only vibes her oh
they never really talked about the menu
somebody but I think they would have
like Barbra eats like maybe like like
chips finger food yeah yeah it looks
good that guy who is designing that's so
rude
so they're so rude to Tom and Tom it's
like so unfair like at the end of the
day like they're not equal partners but
they're partners and Lisa really isn't
their boss anymore she's a partner get
your name on it they will be the reason
people are coming in so like that's not
worth nothing no not at all and not only
that they did put down money right they
each put down like a hundred grand yeah
so I think then being treated like
subordinate like Busboys is not fair
I can only person who sees it that way
it's Ariana every time like they tell
Tom signed it all like reiterate
something that least I said like
Ariana's like well that's weird and
she's right yeah like they're rude to
her they're there to them yeah she's her
to everyone she treats them like
children yeah and it's like don't just
to use them I mean but then it's like
okay saying you had a bar like someone's
pretty much giving all you've to do is
like pay 50k you have a bar that's your
name everywhere someone's doing all of
the work all you have to do is show up
when it's done kind of nice totally um
and the few times you were given a
little bit of responsibility and going
to Vegas and you stayed out until 4:00
a.m. and got drunk and then came to the
meeting that I say being annoying as
[ __ ] honestly I would do the same like
in this instance I'm team Lisa totally
jared leto okay so not only that we had
she-ra she does housewarming party I'm
sure the apartments nice like why did
she move so far I always thought Marina
Del Ray was really I mean I don't know
anything about a la living but when
Stassi was explaining each mean that I
realized it's by the airport the airport
is like an hour from everything but so
how does she get to work all the time
that's works once a week which most of
them do like that's a long drive once a
week yeah and I can't leave does those
girls did it go I know I mean they're
not really friends there I'm like it's
annoying - out of the way but like you
would think they would just had to have
to go for filming right could they be
legit don't give a phone oh my god I'm
Billy vers la la that was crazy the way
she just like follow ball out of the
room and was like that was nuts
it was crazy um it's basic is they used
to be so close I Katie and Billy we were
never close so it's not like that
shocking of a fight
like Lala has is angry yeah and but so
stuck Billy yeah they both have their
visa no sorry take the back Lala has her
reasons
yeah Billy said the thirst is just so
out of control so and I'm like annoyed
that she said it's like her thirst is
paying off but she's becoming more and
more of a main character in the short
line yeah and it's like what girls I am
was about was more so full cast members
like you know that's what they can't say
it's like you weren't first of all you
weren't invited but you weren't included
on the poster and Lala because it's for
people who well are important on the
show not someone who's in the back of
the opening titles right and not to
mention like the day before you insulted
Katie and Kristen so it's like even
right there were so many reasons why she
shouldn't have been tagged like the fact
that this is all about tagging is so
[ __ ] stupid it's hilarious yeah but
nothing was resolved there except her
and Katie like did kind of resolve and
good for Katie for standing her ground
like just because someone apologizes
doesn't mean you have to forgive them
you know but yet essentially you did
know Katie like I accept your apology
but like leave me alone yeah I never
let's go back to how we were please
exclude me from this narrative which I
never asked to be a part of right now
was at the birthday party but earlier in
the day obviously the Tom Sandoval
Ariana Lala of it all oh right oh my god
that was so crazy and honestly I was
like kind of agreeing with Ariana she's
making good points I agree with the
Ariana whole-hearted and by the way Lala
was being such a good friend she like
straight up lie to Jackson Britney she's
like am lying it's not your business
well like Lala doesn't care I mean she
does but she I think she knew that
Ariana would care more if people are
talking about them doing whatever but it
seems as though people knew that Lala
has been with girls but one knew that
Ariana has been with girls and that was
like that's not Tom's unless the big
news wasn't that loud on Ariana hooked
up it's that like Oh ariana is attracted
to girls too so that's not anyone's news
to tell other than Ariana's especially
her boyfriend and like it was really
nice that she forgave him so nobody knew
what she was saying she was like he
doesn't do it maliciously sometimes
benzos stuff that is like so stupid you
know he's like this pure heart I'm like
but you're so dumb but you're so dumb
but so like how can you be mad at
someone when they have good intentions
they're just stupid no and so I
understood complete like I didn't expect
her to like forget him so quickly
especially because she's way harder on
things about wait harder on him about
that are way smaller
um but it was really sweet that like she
just like saw that he was just being a
like a loser idiot yeah but he was being
loser like that is just so not cool
now I have a question that I was
thinking about that nobody brought up
it's a consider cheating you know what I
mean yeah well that's what he I think he
was trying to say he's like I was good I
was really annoyed that night right
because you cheated on me in front of me
right but it's like not really cheating
cuz it's not I don't know like it is but
I guess he was there so it's not unclear
I just like there was like an on an
underlying issue that nobody spoke about
right that's their own private business
exactly um then the boys and they were
smoking cigars and they were like it was
like everyone's faces like knew that
they like something like this is not
good yeah but just like don't talk about
it cuz they're not stupid right and then
eating James talking that Lala by the
way but then he was like he said that
Jackson law had sex right I kind of feel
like they did I kind of feel like they
didn't okay because they're brief and it
was very brief like it was learn tension
it was bad he was with Brittany they
literally we just flirt at the bar I
think that they did kiss and everything
was pretty much on camera if something
more had happened it would have been
brought up then and there and it wasn't
okay I really don't think that it was
just weird that he brought up in Jax got
like so defensive I think James was
saying like oh you looked like see James
it's like oh you hit her you [ __ ] her
it's all the same thing right so he was
just saying you a couple Allah and I
don't think I really don't think that
they did okay it's just so weird that
Britney and all are such good friends
cuz now that I think about it remember
Lala's first season like when they had
it all they had it out in New Orleans
right yeah no it was it was like Mexico
I think whatever Cabo like they and they
had it bad because I pilot and her
friends took their top off in the earth
Lauren and Jax was like very much coming
on to Lala and Britney was only made me
to Lala yeah
like while ever Liz come so far and
that's a Billy was like you think you're
better than everyone cuz you a rich
boyfriend yeah yeah she is but you go
she told it's Martin Scorsese watches
Hannah from pearls she only flies
private she said it's Naima Robert it's
like she is better than everyone they're
sorry and everyone else knows it and
they treat her as such right and even
without all that she's an incredible
woman oh yeah no I [ __ ] love her and
she's looking so good with the brown
hair I'm so here for it right and I was
skeptical but me nappy cuz she never
makes a bad move the conversation about
Ariana like not 180 Reiner to have kids
I comes up every season and it's like
last night Tom Santa Bob was like yeah
it's deal-breaker yeah
then did you watch the boys on watch
what happens I know okay so a few things
that happened honestly was it wasn't
good too many cooks like three people on
the couch it doesn't work and none of
them like could even speak on it it was
the Kourtney Kardashian whoo I feel like
Tom Schwartz maybe Jax Oh Tom Schwartz
actually did a good job he's everyone
loves him and yeah she's a really good
vocabulary yeah he's smart so he he did
well um but Tom Sandoval someone asked
that question like have you guys like
resolved it since then he sounds like
watch a show like it'll resolve itself
maybe she decides to like she's down I
don't know on Twitter she was like not
having it and I honestly just I don't
think that they're right for each other
like I think he used Ariana as an escape
out of a terrible relationship and she
really was intent but I feel like they
just have like different they they've
grown in values they were different like
goals for the future they just see
themselves differently in 10 years and
like not any better or good way I just
don't think they're right for each other
yeah I agree like I'm gonna be shocked
if if they broke up I mean Kristen Jodi
would just have a [ __ ] feel - yeah
but now Kristen Ariana are really good
friends
yeah it's just a weird how like all
these people like have been at their
worst with each other but then at some
point have been best friends with each
other - you know yeah it's just funny
it's really like real I think Kristen
and Stassi but like they're all real
like Ariana and Stassi Kristen yeah
that's the craziest part to me yeah like
especially cuz Ariane they're like
doesn't like [ __ ] around like she
wouldn't do something just for the show
she never really even wanted to be the
show so for her to like to be friends
with Kristen who could only be in a real
way and like they're actually friends
yeah it's so weird like just the
lifecycle of an ephemeral and then but
then the outlier and I think someone who
was really only like a show friend is
scheana and it becomes very increasingly
more clear and it's weird and they talk
about it next week hernia Ariana and her
and Lala it was a Lala and it's just
like they never treated me equally like
finally we need to have this
conversation yeah all she wanted was to
be a which is a week yeah when she got
it for a second she like she wants me
wishes we hope when they're filming but
then when they're not filming like she
wants to go to her show in Vegas and be
later in there and like that's just
that's which is fine but it's like then
you're these three hang out all the time
they live to get like
boyfriend's have read the same but
everything and it's like you don't just
get to be part of that clique and then
have nothing to do with it agreed
you see they're coming out with a wine
yeah but it's good I'll try it
me too I'm gonna try all right well my
throat hurts sufficiently I can't talk
for the rest of the day so we'll be back
tomorrow Thursday we'll do a podcast
only episode before I leave for Mexico
and then Friday snitches closing with
Jackie and then Monday as we said Darrin
will be here be having all things Andy's
baby shower and there were not cameras
there to be confirmed yes he said on his
radio show that there wasn't which I'm
glad because one I feel like I saw
everything
people did ran when there's cameras and
- yeah it's like I saw it I'm good I
feel satiated and then when Darren comes
Alfie I'll get all the deets about who
paid for what thank you guys for tuning
into the millennium morning show we've
got live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube at the
morning shows feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up and then
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast or listen to Spotify
works iTunes works Kasbah works all of
them we'll see you tomorrow bye
you